my organization is called the San Diego
regional data library we do pro bono
data services for nonprofits journalists
and governments we work with a lot of
volunteers and it's a wide variety of
projects sometimes working with crime
street sweeping we do projects involving
weather and water quality this is a
project we've been working on for the
last year for homelessness and because
homelessness is a major issue in the
United States also within San Diego in
particular which is the fourth largest
number of homelessness in our in our
continuum of care which we'll talk about
what those organizations are about a
half a million per year one of the
challenges we have with data and also
one of the opportunities is that
homelessness involves people and data is
an easy way to extract from people or
abstract from people we'd like to try to
keep that humanized we one of our last
meetings we invited an artist who does
portraits of homeless folks Neel shy
Glee to talk with us and I'm not sure
which of us learned more from the other
but his work his experience and our
experiences in working with a variety of
groups we're trying to find ways to use
these data to tell a better story to
remove some of the myths about the
homelessness and have people a better
understanding of the folks who are
actually afflicted by it there's about
half a million homeless in the United
States right now it's been going down
slightly most of those folks are
sheltered we have a substantial shelter
system but there's around a third of
them or not about 200,000 fortunately
most children families do find shelter
but the folks you're likely to meet
outside about 70% of those are men are
living out sleeping rough as I say in
Britain living outside that's not as
much of a problem in San Diego we have
much larger portion of homeless folks
that are outside because the weather's
better about I will show you that number
in a minute here it is so we've got
about 3,600 folks that are unsheltered
they're persistently living outside
sometimes I'll visit shelters but only
one time is about 3,600 outside about
8,000 total these numbers come from an
annual point in time count which is a
large
Jeffery's anybody done the point in time
counts go and volunteered for him you
got every January your local COC the
continuum of care organization will
organize account in which people go out
on one night in January and actually
count folks who are sleeping on the
streets this is really important for
allocating money in fact we've got a an
issue right now in California governor
Newsom just signed an emergency bill to
allocate funds but the federal
government hasn't finished with the
point in time count so they don't know
how to allocate the money the top
organization in the national chain of
organizations that work on homeless
issues is Housing and Urban Development
HUD organizes continuum of cares which
are regions about 600 regions around the
country that HUD allocates money to one
organization that's the manager for that
and then that organization collaborates
and works with all the other
organizations within that region so a
good part of LA County is one continuum
of care San Diego County is another and
the rest of the country with smaller
counties they tend to be multiple
counties multiple cities all working
together those other organizations can
be nonprofits that can be shelters
churches community groups the COC
manager will work with all them and help
to distribute money within those groups
those are also the data sources you're
gonna see for homelessness HUD is the
focal point if you go to the HUD
websites we'll show you a few of those
here you'll find an incredible array of
data just about everything you want
everything you wants there it's not
always easy to find in fact one of the
things I'll give you is links to our
data collections there's a bunch of
files that I found can't find again we
have copies of them but they're great
for analysis but the other place you
might find data is your local COC the
regional task force for the homeless in
San Diego or the Los Angeles County
Housing Authority here they will often
publish datasets on their own sometimes
it much more detail than the federal
government does you'll also find custom
surveys you can find extracts from
homeless management information systems
and local surveys and counts outside of
the federal government's stuff
everything else you pretty much have to
talk to people to get it's very rare to
find the more detailed information
explicitly on the web one of the
processes we had to do to get good
information involved a year-long effort
to locate extract download process and
clean up and digitize a very large stack
of PDF files I will show you that
project in a bit HUD manages those COC
the continuum of care that's about 2.3
billion dollars a year it's a very large
project in San Diego it's about 600
million a year it goes into homeless of
services some of those sites HUD user
gov is the main site for storing
homelessness data that includes special
tabulations of the American Community
Survey which will tell you about 50% or
the median housing costs around the
country you'll get crosswalks there's
some really interesting files here
telling you what the the United States
Postal Service vacancy rates are when a
house doesn't pick up its mail the
Postal Service records that is vacant
HUD has those files you can find out
what vacancy rates are around the
country also lots of crosswalks if you
want to take zip codes and map
demographic data into tracts zip codes
and tracks are well first of all you
shouldn't do that because zip codes are
terrible but if you have to do that you
need crosswalk files to link those two
geographies together and those are at
HUD user gov HUD exchange that info is
another site that HUD uses to
collaborate with the COCs the continuum
of care organizations when they report
their point in time counts they got
every every year in January they count
homeless folks we're sleeping outdoors
the shelters report how many people are
in beds they send that to HUD HUD puts
that at HUD exchanged on info now you
can't get to those files because they're
they're private a lot of them actually
have people's names in them but there
are some files here that you can
download again they're kind of hard to
find
I've got other links to them which I'll
show you in a bit the most important
stuff at HUD exchange is the point in
time count methodologies if you want to
work with point in time count data it's
really important to know exactly what's
going on on the data stuff changes from
year to year and this site will tell you
how the methodology works our regional
group
the regional task force for the homeless
runs that point in time count and they
published some data and not others we've
got a kind of a spotty collection of
data i've been collecting that so again
if you're interested in mana lysing it
my sites probably the first stop but if
you talk to them you can often get get
specific files for particularly years
the data management's a little spotty
but there's often some really amazing
information that's available if you talk
to folks the big one is a point in time
count we've talked about this a bit this
is what the data looks like for 2010 i
happen to have a friend who digitized
the data in 2000 and he was hired to do
this he's a GIS guy so i got that file
it's really hard to get the other files
to get point data they the way they do
the counts is they send out people all
over the county in San Diego County all
625 tracks have at least two people that
go out they have a paper map and when
they find someone sleeping out they mark
it on the map
those maps then get tabulated and
reported back to HUD with a number of
homeless sleepers per tract but those
maps get filed and they have position
information on them which sometimes gets
gets geocoding you can see we've got
downtown area down on the bottom here is
where most of the homeless folks are
staying Ocean Beach
anybody been to Ocean Beach it's kind of
an interesting interesting place yeah
they've got a homeless issue just south
of the pier around the pier area and a
couple other parts of town as well but
it's really centered around around
downtown and because there's so much to
homelessness downtown that San Diego
Downtown Partnership has been which is
originally started as a as a group of
churches and other business
organizations has been has received
funding for the last seven years to
count do their own count of homeless
sleepers downtown for about 350 blocks
this is an amazing data set it's just
like the point time counts except it's
seven years on a monthly basis we can do
all sorts of incredible stuff with this
unfortunately it's all in PDF files they
will go out the same way that the point
in time count works you send out some
people with a map they mark where the
sleepers are and then they add up the
number
if counts on that map and write that
down and you can get that data what they
don't do is digitized the maps it's a
lot of work when I found this I realized
that we can use this to look at how
homeless clusters
according to changes in land use we can
look for what happens when you put in a
new bathroom or a new park what happens
when you put in the tent that they put
down in East Village in 2017 what
happened during the hepatitis outbreak
these are all things that we can look at
geographically if we have this data
geocoded but we've got 350 paper maps
and no budget so how do we do that we'll
talk a lot about that another local
organization for Los Angeles is the Los
Angeles homeless housing authority they
have some really fascinating data which
includes both the point in time counts
and surveys of individuals for how long
they've been on the streets drug use
sexual assaults alcohol use everything
else you might want to know about these
folks has gone into probably 30,000
points 30,000 records unfortunately that
was difficult to get to we managed to
get it through an organization called
the economic roundtable and again these
files are hard to find I've saved them
so you can so you can analyze them this
is a view of how homelessness and
land-use are related the region's
the ones that are colored you can see
the the fade or the color scale down
below it's a relative scale from from
least to worst
yellow is Skid Row there's an actual
Skid Row it's in the yellow spot and
then the dots show you different land
use it's fairly typical that homeless
folks cluster in places where they're
not going to be bothered by a lot of
people so they tend to stay out of the
way unsurprising and that includes a lot
of light industrial there are a
substantial amount of homelessness in in
multifamily but it tends to be mostly in
the light industrial heavy industrial
and commercial sectors the organization
that liberated that data was the
economic roundtable really really
interesting group these
folks Bulldogs they often get in trouble
they've had a couple lawsuits over
overuse of data because they managed to
get enough data to be able to do a
predictive model for homelessness that
was the county didn't like that one so
much for variety of reasons but we do
appreciate the amount of effort that
goes into to getting data out to be to
be usable they've done data dives with
data kind you can find their site at
economics economic RT org again the
files that I was able to get from them
are a little difficult to find right now
so I'll give you links to those and
those are all on the san diego regional
data library's data repository in our
homelessness collection the data the san
diego.org if you go to our site you'll
see both the los angeles datasets a
bunch of stuff from san diego data
across the whole space here there's
quite a lot of useful information this
is one that we send researchers to quite
a bit because some of these files are
really tough to find the oh and here's
them this good this one got in the wrong
spot if you go to PI data our website
slash PI data you'll get links to this
presentation and links to all the other
sites that include this data let's go
back to now I mentioned that from the
San Diego Downtown Partnership we got a
stack of PDF files of handwritten Maps
credible data set not digitized so we
worked on started working on digitizing
it one of the first groups I talked to
was the students of Corey and Burgess at
Kearney high we did a lot of data
projects with these folks she's awesome
she's really dedicated to social issues
she's really dedicated to date in
computer science she's got a really
amazing group of students and so he said
hey let's let's do a data project let's
get you this data for one of the
neighborhood's Gaslamp anybody been to
Gaslamp san diego familiar with it yeah
it's a party
party town very long and vertical it has
a substantial homeless population but
clustered in certain areas it's small as
a Ria's a neighborhood so it made a good
neighborhood to us to work with on this
data set
though the way that you georeference
paper maps when you take a paper map and
you have to figure out how does the
pixels on the map relate to latitude and
longitude is complicated and difficult
the tools for it both in QGIS which is
an open-source tool that I use mostly an
arcmap which they had access to are
tough to use really hard to train on so
we were looking for a different way of
doing it and crank came up with a really
simple one that was really quite
brilliant
you can use arcmap tools to create web
forms the kind of form that you'd send
with somebody if they're gonna go out in
the field and record where graffiti is
or look for street lights that are
burned out you make a little web form it
can poke on the map where something is
and record that as a data point then you
can extract that data later well they
just did a web form for downtown and the
students put the web form on one part of
their screen and they put the map on the
other part of their screen I just
eyeballed it I was little skeptical
turned out to work really really really
well much more accurate than I expected
and we got some great results out of it
this is a student analysis of homeless
concentrations over time they're done
heat maps for different periods and what
they did by looking at this was they
figured out that there's one particular
cluster you can see this in the October
1 to January 1 2018 that is related to
closing of a particular theater the gas
I'm 15 theater closed down
it has awnings and now it has nobody in
it so it became a magnet for homeless
folks trying to stay out of the weather
that was a really powerful insight that
the students got I was were quite
surprised I even went on to to Google
Streetview
to survey the building and figure out
that's what was going on they also
looked at comparing rent to homeless
counts and this was precisely one of the
reasons we created this data set was to
give students a way to engage in a
social issue do it from a data
perspective and in a way that that even
high school students can work with now
once we finish that we need to go
digitize the rest of the data and I did
want to do something a little more
accurate than eyeballing maps so we had
to do a little more innovation because
like I said
the standard way of geo referencing a
map just takes too long was it was very
much more difficult than we needed so
what it did was wrote some software in
Python of course to extract the images
from all the PDFs turns out it's a
little trickier than you'd think
the way that PDFs store images is kind
of crazy there's a lot of a lot of
formats they're based on facts from 25
30 years ago so you have to work around
that but once you get the images out
we used an optical character recognition
library to figure out what map is what
they have the name of the map on them we
can find that so Cortes or Gaslamp and
then we the programs would organize all
those maps into jobs create a ticket on
github that when you click through that
ticket you would get a annotation tool
this is an annotation tool called via
from the visual geometry group at Oxford
it's a it's a really awesome tool it's a
single file HTML file you just download
that one HTML file stick it whatever
fire up the Python simple HTTP server
you can run this tool and it's for
annotating images for doing vision
processing if you've if you've done any
computer vision work you spend an awful
lot of your time drawing boxes around
cats or whatever you're trying to
recognize if you want to you want to
find people or dogs and in a diagram you
have to like draw say here's a cat and
you have to do that a thousand times
so we used that tool to do two
annotations on these images the first
one this is a job that was constructed
by the code so that when the student or
the volunteer clicked into it they only
had to do this job you can see where it
says - you'll see a little yellow box
there there's actually four of those
yellow boxes
those are annotations of specific
intersections you draw the box around
the intersection and then in a pulldown
list say which intersection it is we
know what where that intersection is we
have the latitude and longitude for and
with three of those points the fourth
ones a bonus with three of those points
you can create now find transformation
matrix that lets you go from pixels to
latitude and longitude that gives us the
second job this is what what those final
regions look like the
second job is to do exactly the same
thing but to digitize the positions of
the homeless sleepers the marks on the
map so that you'll see the number two of
a number one you draw a circle around
that type in a one real simple task
most the time these take about 15
minutes to an hour - depending on how
much data there is and it goes a couple
other data they'd annotate we could
easily break this up get in dozens of
volunteers and do this over the course
of a couple weeks we got most of it done
in a couple weeks the scrag lers jobs
finished off after after about two
months that gave us a really fantastic
data set the cleanup involved geo
merging two census blocks because we got
a lot of tude and longitude we I read
that the census blocks and then we can
do some missing data imputation because
three of our files didn't work if you go
to the PI data la length that I
mentioned earlier at our San Diego
regional data library's website you'll
find a Google collab notebook that walks
you through generating this particular
map it's a good exit I actually use it a
lot for training people in geo pandas
which is one of these astoundingly
awesome tools in the Python toolset here
you can see what that dataset looks like
it homelessness in San Diego this is the
total count the blue line is the
official count it's the numbers that
they took from adding up all the marks
on all the maps it's a longer data we
didn't get images for everything before
2014 but we did get the the data number
or the or the number of sleepers you can
see the big rise in 2016 through 2017
you can see the two spots that are
missing which we imputed
probabilistically we took the number of
folks that were sleeping in each region
prior to outside the missing regions and
we just raised geometrically added them
back in on a block-by-block basis so
it's a fairly it's basically if you try
to do correlations across those months
so get the same coalition's you've got
the previous month
but the graphs work out just great
you'll also notice at the very end
there's a divergence in the two lines
it's not an error the difference there
is in 2017 HUD came up with new
multipliers for
what you multiply a count when people
are sleeping in a car or a tent it's
like one point one seven and one point
four six we didn't want to put those
multipliers in the data so we left them
off but the official numbers have them
so that's why the diversions there in
San Diego the homelessness issue it
diverges by neighborhood as well the
largest neighborhood is the one down in
the southeast corner you can see the hot
spot down in yellow and green
that's East Village East Village is less
in dust but it's more industrialized
it's got less entertainment more
warehouses you know more large
laundromats and so the homeless folks
tend to cluster there because they try
to stay out of the way of people you'll
see a little bit more in the North
section that you shaped block is Horton
Plaza which was previously a mall and is
now being redeveloped I think into a
Business Park and there's a couple other
spots here that I'm not precisely sure
exactly what they are because I didn't
you know put the underlying map but it's
mostly East Village East Village is also
where the largest rise and fall has come
over the years that was one of the
questions we're trying to figure out is
what what's the reason for this
unfortunately because we only have
downtown we don't know precisely what
happens when to where homeless stay in
response to policing it's quite possible
that the rise and fall was because the
police were more aggressive policing
outside downtown so homeless folks moved
into East Village and then they got more
aggressive in East Village and moved
them back out we're still looking for
data on police stops to try to figure
out exactly what that is but the one
instrument thing that was really
interesting was to see if there's any
connections between that rise and fall
of the hepatitis outbreak we had a major
hepatitis outbreak but I unfortunately
forgot exactly when it was
fortunately you can go to google and ask
them this is Google search trends for
San Diego hepatitis we just looked for
the spot where there was the most news
articles on it that turns out to be
September of 2017
slightly around that time one of the
responses was to put a homeless tent
it's one of those big tents you might if
you had a really big wedding outdoors
you get the big white tent they had one
of those basically covers a whole
parking lot that went in in late 2017
but as you can see that doesn't appear
to be any particular connection between
these things this is one of the things
that I've had to get used to over time
is reporting false results if you've
been following the replication crisis in
just about every field of science you
know that there's a publication bias so
I try to get myself worked up when I say
hey we found nothing in this case we
didn't find anything we looked at about
six other items you'll see these in the
Google collab notebook we've got some
really interesting data sets in San
Diego on this side on the left you've
got the homeless data set and the other
side is pedestrian traffic
we have pedestrian traffic data by hour
actually by 15-minute intervals for
years and we have that because we have
smart street lamps which a lot of folks
are not quite as excited about because I
see them as Big Brother I'm a little on
the fence on this one if you go down we
got about 4400 smart street lamps that
have four cameras and a big one gigabyte
Atom processor on them they are watching
you all the time they claim they don't
do face recognition but they do object
recognition and of the objects they
recognize of course are cars and people
so they've got virtual lines crossing
sidewalks and those are called walkways
it's for some reason you walk across the
walkway not in the walkway but you'll
get reports of how many people are
crossing those walkways each time it's a
little bit weird data mote the most
frequent speed across these walkways is
five meters a second to kind of work out
what five meters a second looks like
it's pretty much running so either
everybody in San Diego is running all
the time or another on scooters or but
data's wrong we think the data's kind of
wrong but we took the counts and break
them out by time we'll just assume those
are right actually look
pretty much what you'd expect the yellow
in the center there that's basically the
hot spot of the gas lamp district this
is a Saturday evening so we're looking
at party traffic and looking for
correlations to homeless try to avoid
places that are have high pedestrian
populations yeah we didn't find anything
partly because you can see there's a lot
of pedestrian traffic happening in East
Village that's probably not party
traffic it's probably lots of other
folks going to and from apartments but
regardless we didn't find strong
correlations with that one either
looked at crime a wide variety of crime
we also in Santa us really awesome crime
data sets that go back for several years
in this one the gross correlations don't
work out very well you can see the
Gaslamp and Horton claws we're not
entirely sure why Horton Plaza is so
high it might be that these are alcohol
violations so it might be folks drinking
in the park to the north of it and
they're getting nicked by the cops but
there is you can see in the East Village
a hotspot for crime this probably is
there's a couple bars down there I think
mission there is a mission brewery down
there is that way yeah so it might be
that it might actually be the ballpark
is pretty close to where that is just to
the west of it so that might be part of
the problem we're not real sure either
regardless we didn't find a strong
correlation fact there's not a lot of
correlation there at all we get a little
bit of correlation between the lunch
traffic on Wednesday nights and
Wednesday day but you can see the yellow
sleepers 0.16 not not all out there
which is actually kind of good I mean
you one of the myths that a lot of folks
who work in homelessness want to dispel
is that homelessness aren't necessarily
a high crime population in San Diego
almost all of our crime it's in
remarkably safe City one of the safest
in the country most of our crime crumbs
from car thefts and a drunken assaults
so if you're downtown or you live in my
town Pacific Beach that's where you're
like most likely to face violent crime
and it's always going to be somebody
who's has been
yeah recently at a bar homeless folks
aren't spending a lot of time in bars so
they're not really that much of a
problem on this the crime is so crime
subpoena is a fascinating dataset and in
particularly connected to homelessness
but it's also got some other interesting
features to it one of which we we use to
test doing some analysis on some
temporal analysis particularly using
fast Fourier transforms are familiar
with with FFTs you know basically yeah
so an FFT is a way of breaking a signal
down into its constituent frequencies if
you could take a signal and add up a
bunch of sine waves you can create any
signal you want by adding up those sine
waves the the fast Fourier transform
allows you to break it up that way what
it does when you're doing a signal where
you've got a data set a time series is
you're looking for periodicity of a
frequent event so for our temporal
analysis of crime you should expect
quite a lot of that these are what I
call rhythm Maps the horizontal axis is
the day of the week soiree these numbers
and not letters the vertical axis is
hour of the day and you can see a lot of
patterns this is I love this set because
it's got more patterns than anything
you'll any data so you'll ever work with
you can see the five o'clock law the
vertical yellow lines across most least
things you can see in burglary the
Friday night commercial crime and the
mid day from the mid day weekday
burglaries you can see sex crimes mostly
happen in the middle of week
I've asked lots and lots of crime
analysts why that is nobody knows but so
we should be able to find some patterns
if we look at at these data sets this is
a temporal analysis another rhythm map
the week of the years on the bottom hour
of the day and you can see that most of
our crimes
alcohol crimes happening in the
afternoons in the middle of the summer
that strong line down the middle of
summer that's a fourth of July weekend
and that line is entirely there because
of Pacific Beach seriously when we
cancelled when we outlawed alcohol on
Pacific Beach that line disappears it's
it's a really amazing pattern so let's
go see if we can
we can we can reorganize some of those
things in this heat map there's one hour
per cell there's a two there's two weeks
two times 168 cells per row and when you
organize it by two weeks you can see it
neatly lays out into hourly sari daily
and weekly patterns the stronger yellow
red lines going vertically are the
weekends and then the the yellow stripes
or five o'clock period so you can see
there's a very strong weekly and daily
pattern here so let's see if that works
out in our FFT it does fast Fourier
transforms any kind of signal analysis
like that is kind of expecting that you
have an infinitely long signal and you
don't so you get all sorts of weird
noise because you're you've got cut off
on the end you're supposed to throw in a
Hamming window on this and I don't think
I did it on this one it didn't really
matter all that much you still get all
the crap in there but what you do see
you see a really strong line on the top
that's 24 hours that is that is the
amplitude of the signal at that that
oscillates at 24 hours we have a daily
period you also see a really sort of
strong signal over there that's 168
hours
that's our weekly period so analysis
checks out it actually works what
happens when we do homelessness yeah we
get nothing
strongest period is 42 hours I can think
of no good reason why there's a 42 our
site for a 42 months cycle in our data
just none at all three and four months
you might come up with a good
explanation for but probably not this
analysis should have showed us a
12-month period if it existed but as it
turns out you get used to this when you
analyze data in San Diego there's no
seasons so we don't have 12 months
cycles either we tend to have cycles it
was correspond with holidays that's why
the fourth of July cycles they're in the
crime data set but the homeless don't
don't let you know they don't come and
go for you know Christmas and
Thanksgiving so we don't we don't get
any of those patterns there's there's a
lot you can do with this unfortunately
again like I said I like reporting
negative results we're finding that
homelessness has the only real strong
pattern there is at
big hump that comes out in at 60 months
and we are still working on figuring out
why that is if this sort of stuff
excites you we would love to have some
help this is an open source project I'd
say and you are welcome to join us the
one that we're working on slowly really
excited about is using doing machine
image recognition to complete the
missing fields the missed the three
missing months and all the months that
have come after that again about a year
of data that we need to go through the
digitization process with but we have
about 20,000 annotations of digits some
of them are here let anybody dud the
digit recognition machine learning
example he's familiar with that yeah
okay so those digits look like good ones
no there are pain we've got all sorts of
crud in there the the example data set
you use for for object recognition has
nice clean handwritten digits ours have
the residue of circles and streets on
them so we're looking for some folks up
to a challenge to try to get rid of that
and turn those numbers back into
geographic positions that we can use to
to complete out the data set we've also
got a lot of questions that are open we
have a site one of the sub sites of the
data library is called insights and it's
a simple question and answer site we
collect questions from the public often
I have to go around and beat on bushes
to get questions in this case we
wouldn't talk to a whole bunch of folks
some of which were actually economic
roundtable experts in homelessness folks
who are working to SDSU folks who are
working in the city of San Diego and
asking them what do you want to know
about homelessness and these are some of
the things they came up with they're
particularly interested the impacts of
policing what happens when police change
their patterns of where they do policing
do you get movement in the homeless
folks and what's the relationship to
services what happens when you open a
new bathroom that's happened in Fault
Line park I believe that's the last
question down there how do public
bathrooms affect for homeless people
sleep fault line Park had a bathroom
that opened and closed several times
there was you know it definitely did
homeless to the park that's why they
closed it but we don't really know what
that looks like from a geographic
perspective they're also looking at how
changes in vacant parking lots and
whether they're homeless folks clustered
near trolley stops I did have some some
slides on the trolley stops one really
fascinating analysis I realized that I
didn't understand it well enough to
really explain it so I took the slide
out but the gist of it is we've got a
guy who is basically doing hypothesis
testing on with the distributions of
homeless folks you're it's a Monte Carlo
method where you go and distribute if
you propose that homeless folks cluster
near trolley stops you can
programmatically create that you put a
Gaussian distribution around the trolley
stops and when you do a hypothesis test
it's based on a nearest neighbor
analysis really interesting process but
it's things like that that we're able to
do we have this really low-level
demographic information one that I
didn't mention is we also have from
economic roundtable this incredible
collection of probably twenty five
hundred points of data from surveys
individual surveys with homeless folks
looking at how long they've been on the
streets what substance abuse problems
they might have you know sex age what
where they were born all sorts of stuff
like that I think there's forty columns
I would love to have some folks who are
interested in exploring the issue doing
some basic descriptive analysis on that
if this is the sort of stuff is really
interesting again it's a link to the
blog post that has links to everything
else including our our main data sets
and again we are but happy to help if
you've got an interest in doing some
volunteer analysis on these sorts of
things all right thank you
they have a time for questions
is there any specific analysis of Ocean
Beach we haven't done anything
particular is simply because we don't
have good data the area there are some
as you saw there was a lot of points
down around Ocean Beach it seems to me
that the Ocean Beach the homeless at
Ocean Beach were a very different
character than the ones that are
downtown a different set of issues and
there are there is survey data but I I
think it's mostly conducted downtown and
I don't think they're going up to Ocean
Beach for those sorts of things I
usually just go talk to the some of the
researchers because they spent a lot of
time talking to homeless folks and they
can give you a basic hunch on stuff but
we don't really have good data to
separate those those two regions out do
you have any pockets from well the city
doesn't actually have much data one of
the questions here actually got from
Omar passing staff and there they can't
they have to work with the other
agencies to get data as well I was
actually kind of surprised I'm always
surprised by this you'd think that
there's more data sharing going on
behind the scenes and there actually is
but there isn't so an API would be
interesting but we have to get access to
it first and that that's just gonna
require some footwork the regional task
force for the homeless has a new
executive director that's a little more
open with that but I haven't managed to
get to get all those files out yet we're
looking for a good lawyer to go lean on
people for with a PRA request
could you basically Creek a little bit
too
in there
the confident gonna be more specific
which which complex though right I'm not
I'm not as warm formed on that model as
I'd like to be the the conflict was that
it required a lot of administrative data
that came from the county which the
county did not agree with economic
roundtable they had rights to use and so
the county said you got to give us back
and economic roundtables like yeah no we
this model is awesome and it needs to
get out in the world so that issue the
way that I hope it works is that as
everybody know there's lots of these
sorts of conflicts a play out you see
them in a news everybody behind the
scenes really wants to make this work
nobody's nobody's like yeah I know I
don't want to solve homelessness they
all they all really care about it but
there's a lot of other issues that they
need to work through and I'm hoping that
the existence of of models like that
they can help people intervene before
folks become homeless makes it paves the
way for these agencies to release the
data and figure out how to share it it's
it's all privacy encumbered right it's
it's stuff like coming out of you know
people who filing for unemployment so
it's really not easy just to hand that
stuff over to us another group you
really gotta do a lot of foot work
before you can make that data flow yes
yeah so the the if we if we had a really
good handle on how to solve a way to
solved it it's really complicated and
the root causes depends a little bit on
how you phrase that a lot of it is kind
of the there's a mindset to it the one
that I hear most frequently late lately
is that it's a failure support systems
that in order for a person become
homeless there's a bunch of stuff that
has to go wrong it's not just they lost
job it's not just that they had a health
problem it's a whole bunch of things
there's a path of going down that you
you go through before you get to the
point of being homeless and so some of
the work is going on and trying to fix
those things that happen before then so
but then when somebody does become
homeless it's like quicksand it drugs
you Dan dragged you down if you can't
afford to live somewhere you can't
afford a shower you can't afford to go
on a job interview so one of the
solutions there is called rapid
rehousing you just get the person in
homeland into a stable home situation
immediately there's also a change in the
last ten years of called housing first
which it used to be there was a very
moralistic attitude that you had to get
clean and sober before you got home and
now they're saying look you just we just
give you a home first then we solve the
problem part of the issue there is that
in San Diego the top 36 users of
services the ones who call 9-1-1 the
most the ones who get hit by cars the
most after drinking they cost this they
cost the county 40 million dollars a
year it's a million dollars a person for
a lot of for the top users getting those
folks in the housing fast it's a really
valuable thing to do so that's one of
the things that we're trying to look at
is is how does the what are the
economics behind it that's a little
difficult because it intersects with
people's individual characteristics that
require survey data and that's hard to
get right thank you very much
you
[Applause]